→ほど立ったんですけども
なんだろう、なんかね、あんまり辛くないです
わかんない夏になるとめっちゃ食べたくなるかもしんないけど
でも、お菓子がなくてもお前ら意外と行けるぞ
いやほんとに
最初のお菓子禁止しますって言った二日間ぐらい
ぐらいはすごい辛かったんですけど
３日４日ぐらいになると
本当にね、お菓子のことを考えずにすみますね
全然行ける
ま、わかんない。
なんでこんなことになったかもよくわかんないですけど
お菓子食わなくても全然イケますよ、実際ね。
お菓子我慢して、その分美味しい飯を食えばいいかな
お菓子禁止キャンペーン………
結構余裕です(ドヤッ)
ニキビもね〜、できなくなった気がするな
うん。多分、できてないと思う。
ニキビというかね、肌荒れが少なくなった気がする。
したらとしても、多分、寝不足だ。
肌の調子がすごい良くなったのと
最近、「よく細くなった」と言われるんすよ。
体重は変わってないんですけど、なんか
顔の、この
前よりちょっとシュッっとしてる気がします。
わかんないけどね。
体調、結構良くなった。
ちょっとよかったら、是非やってみてください
意外と余裕だから。
お菓子禁止、全然余裕でイケます！
で！な！
ま、そもそもの話をするよ
まず、僕がそもそも
というまずは理由を言いましょう
で、その理由に基づいて
→づけを僕は曖昧にしていた、今まで。
お菓子の定義づけをしっかりした上で
今後のキャンペーンを続けていこうと思っているので
今日はとりあえず、そのお菓子を禁止にした理由、
そして、お菓子の定義づけ
そこをまず話していこうと思います。
まず！
お菓子を禁止にした理由なんですけども
簡単に言うと、ま、ご存知の方も多いと思うですけど
僕、
もう、夜ご飯とかお昼ご飯がお菓子だけの時もあるし
たけのこの里、2箱食う時もあった
あ、ちょっと食べたくなってきちゃった
いや！食わねーよ！
ま、主食をお菓子にするのはまずいかなと
体がぶっ壊れるなと思ってやめました、お菓子。
ま、お菓子にはね、その、
砂糖がたくさん入ってたり、
甘味料とかね、ちょっとそういうのがたくさんあるんで！
砂糖のみを摂取するみたいな感じが
すごい悪い、体に悪いって感じなんで
やめてました。
糖尿病とかになるかもしんないからね
ていうのが理由であります。
つまり！俺の中の！お菓子の定義は！
俺はそんな気がする
砂糖の量が異常に多くてね
なんか、こうね、なんか、
甘いお菓子、いいよねぇ〜。
お菓子、いいよぉ〜
お菓子、本当にいい
何の話してんだ
とりあえずね、なんかね、砂糖がね、
ある程度入ってて、お菓子って言ってたら
それはもう「お菓子」ってなりますよ
アイスもそうですし、
レッドブルとかもジュースだよ！
ていうのを全部「お菓子」なんですよ！
僕の中ではね！
そこで今回ですよ！
私のこの定義に基づいた上で
お菓子とはみなされないように
と思いまして
先日、なんか、チョコレートを研究している
という方にお会いしまして
相談したんですけど
これはもう、大丈夫だ。と
このチョコレートなら食っていいよ、みたいな
チョコレートを、ちょっと、紹介していただいたので
ちょっと、買ってしまいました。
もう、ちょっと、空いてるんですけど、
こちらです
というチョコレートです
みんな！これは！
お菓子じゃない！！
いや！
まぁ。
違うんスよ！ちょっと違う！
まず、お、まえ、定義聞いたっしょ
定義の通りでございます
このチョコレートのまず説明をしましょう
このドモーリ・クリオーロ100というチョコレートは
お菓子禁止にした理由に基づくお菓子というの定義の中には
これは含まれない、例外タイプです
なので、僕の中ではOKだし
チョコレートくんもOKと言っていただいたので
これOKです
このサイズで800円です。
高い…。
いや〜、待て。そんな、おい。
めちゃくちゃチョコレート食いたいって気分でもないから
もう、なんか、もう
お菓子禁止しすぎて、そういう概念はないから
これも、なんかもう、仕方なく食ってやろうぐらいの感じで買いました
全然そういう、チョコレート食いたい欲とかないんで
(ジュルッ)
わ！これ、やばっ！え！
希少種、クリオーロ
マジで言ってんの？
世界で0.01%しかないチョコですよ
全部カカオで作られています
つまり！チョコレートではありません
カカオです！！
お〜。
これは僕の中でセーフなんですよ
砂糖が入ってない
二か月ぶりにチョコレートを食べてみます
0.01%だよ！
え！待って！本当にそんな低いか？
ガチだった！
ま、そもそもカカオっていうものは何かていう話しましょう
ちょっと何個かありまして
誕生日に食えばよかった。
開けますよ
あ、こういうサイズね
もう世界で0.01%チョコレートですからね
これか〜
これがカカオ100%のチョコレートです
口コミとかによると
「すごい美味しい」って書いてありました
砂糖も使われてなくて
「カカオだけなのに美味しい」って言われてたんで
俺も食わざるを得んと思ってね
早速いただきます
大丈夫だ、砂糖入ってないんだろ？
でもめっちゃいい匂いするんだけど
怖いなぁ。砂糖、本当に入ってないかなぁ
大丈夫、これ、本当に大丈夫なやつだ。
いただきます！
(ポリッポリッ)
あら、あれれ〜？
チョコレートじゃないかぁ？
あ〜、風味はすごいいいんすよ
チョコレートのすごい美味しい風味はするんですけど
あのお菓子の「お」の字もない感じ
風味はすごいいいんですけど
ちょっと僕には苦いかな
このチョコの美味い風味は感じられますが
甘さは一切ございません！！
ちょっと高いんですけど、よかったら是非買ってみてください。
じゃあな。